and there's controversy over the film
let's talk about why there's controversy
yeah and i feel like there's going to
actually be more controversy with that
new title
um because now it's kind of spelling out
exactly what it is
and uh what's the content the
controversy is um
it has i think when people see it
there's going to be new controversy too
there's a lot of
child actors um which this isn't even
the controversy now this will probably
be more
once people watch it so we have like all
these eight ten-year-old kids you know
the lead two girls were 13 and 14 or 13
or 14 at the time now that now
everyone's like 18 because it took so
long
to come out but um at the time the two
league girls are 13 and 14 years old and
then we have like a
boy who was like seven or eight and then
the nine-year-old victim the
ten-year-old you know actress um so we
have all this
um kind of violent attitude i guess
towards children and
tons of you know cussing and lots of uh
kind of bullying
but it's done in such a realistic way or
it kind of looks like it's really
happening which it wasn't you know if
you look
you know between takes everyone's just
laughing i mean the lead
actress and little boy are actually
brother and sister you know and the moms
are like
there the whole time supervising
everything we had a professional acting
coach who was there the entire time you
know watching everything
um but when you're watching it you don't
know all that and when you're watching
it there's just
a lot of vulgarity towards children so
that's probably going to create a whole
new kind of
controversy i'm thinking um but what's
going on right now
is uh the fact that it was you know
based on the murder of a real
nine-year-old
um and a very vicious one and one that
is one of the most popular
murder cases in recent memory and so a
lot of people
trying to think of a way to explain it
it's okay for the news
to be like hey
this just happened let's talk about it
everybody watch
the news and give us ratings so we can
all
you know get money and and and
sensationalize this
um but it's not okay what i've learned
is when an independent filmmaker says
okay instead of spending five minutes on
this topic and making money
i'm gonna spend five years trying to
understand it
um so for me there's no controversy
whatsoever for me it's
i'm the one actually trying to do with
the news i think is
glamorizing or sensationalizing i want
to understand
why this happens um but unfortunately
the public they look at it as oh this
guy is making money
this guy is just looking for uh
you know so an an easy thing to make a
film about um so i guess that that's the
controversy if that's even kind of
answering the question is um
people don't people it's okay for the
news to sensationalize murder but people
don't want to see a film made about it
and i
actually don't understand i guess i
could try to understand
why people are mad about that but i
actually don't because
she basically made fun of alyssa for
trying to kill herself uh once she was
arrested she tried to kill herself by
scratching her arms open with her nails
which i think is
a very painful way to die and i don't
think she was doing it for attention
because the girl
already was on prozac and known to have
all these mental issues and hardy had
already tried to kill herself and had
self-inflicted wounds that you could see
from the pictures they were using all
over her arm
and uh and it was known not to make that
public to like her friends you know and
stuff like that
and so anyways this was making fun of
this 15 year old who we don't even know
if she actually did it you know or why
she did it she was making
fun of this girl for trying to kill
herself and i thought that was the most
sickening thing
i'd ever seen is uh for the news to make
fun of a kid trying to kill himself
like what the [ __ ] and um
to me that was i guess contra
you know i mean if anything's
controversial i don't understand
basically why it wasn't that because
that outraged me so much that that's
what made me go okay i want to make a
film about that because it reminded me
of the calm mind thing
you know she's making all this money and
sensationalizing
um this murder of this child and making
fun of this other child
and she's um probably a millionaire i'm
assuming you know
because of it and it's totally okay and
i
to me that that just sickens me is i
want to understand
you know something more than that you
know i want to understand why this stuff
happens and
um but apparently that's the person
who's controversial so
you